Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so a lot of you
guys have asked me who is the fastest version
of the flash so I'm in a rank all of the comic
book speedsters in the TV show speedsters
a lot of people we haven't seen on the TV
show yet.
So here we go.
There's also a new round of the flash ring
giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything during the break.
So start with the comic book speedsters and
then I'll do the ones on the TV show just
because there are so many even in what's considered
the classic flash family so there about 19
people on this list but there are couple Yachts
there people like zoom who have really weird
powers who are kind of cheating.
So you have people that are fast because they
run in a straight line faster than anyone
else and then you have people's powers theoretically
make them faster than other people, regardless
of the way they use them.
So I tried to account for that with this list,
so starting with the slowest working our way
to the fastest jive West Ginger Wally West's
son he also had a daughter, but she's way
higher on the list, so jive as powers just
enabled him to take advantage of the speed
force make really big muscles get really strong
for brief periods of time but that didn't
really enable him to run that fast.
So that's why he is technically the slowest
then you have a Liberty Bell who's a golden
age character.
They didn't actually use the speed force she
actually rang a special bell that gave her
powers for a really brief.
But she could still run much faster than a
normal person enough to make her superhero.
So next on the list.
Max Mercury he's actually from the 1830s,
but gaining powers from a shaman and briefly
learn to use the speed force to intuitively
travel through time.
So he was fast, but he's pretty low on the
list.
He never really learned to use the speed force
or tap into it directly away some of the more
contemporary speedsters that next on the list
is Johnny quick one of the people to develop
the speed force formula the one you hear them
say out loud like Jesse quick.
So he was one of the first people to do that
in enabled him to access the speed force but
again it didn't enable him to tap into it
as much as the other speedsters.
So we should actually make the distinction
that there are a couple different ideas when
it comes to speedsters getting there powers
from the speed force there something that
they called the speed field which almost all
the speedsters draw there speed from and then
there is the actual speed force, so tapping
into the speed force in benefiting from the
speed force are two different things.
So all speedsters benefit from the speed force
with the exception of people like zoom.
I'll explain that in the second.
There are very few speedsters that do not
get their powers from the speed force, so
moving down the list just a little bit faster
trajectory who was a Lex Corp. speedster created
during the 52 comics that he was able to turn
powers on turn them off.
It was almost a velocity nine type situation,
but I know they use her in a slightly different
way on the TV show all explained that when
I rank the TV show speedsters.
So trajectory in the comics still got her
powers artificially pretty fast, but still
pretty low on the list, so the next is Jesse
quick the daughter of Johnny quick who also
use the same formula to get her powers, she
would speak the formula and take advantage
of the speed force, so here's where it starts
to get a little confusing because we get into
multiple Wally West, so the next on the list
is the current kid flash the African-American
Wally West.
So, I know he debuted during the new 52 because
they wreck on that recently he is now much
younger.
He's like a high school age speedster just
learning about his powers.
So he will be fast one day but right now he's
towards the middle of the list next on the
list is the rival Golden age Edward Clariss
from the comics he was the very first reverse
flash of Jay Garrick Sara he became the first
velocity nine speedster that was eventually
lost into the speed force then later came
back out as pure energy and possess the body
of Max Mercury for a time there are a couple
velocity nine speedsters on this list, and
it does make them almost as fast as the traditional
contemporary speedsters, but not quite as
fast.
So next on the list is Jay Garrick his ultimate
rival just a little bit faster but Jay Garrick
in terms of classic speedsters is towards
the bottom of the list like he never got quite
as fast as they like Barry or classic Ginger
Wally West.
So next up is inertia who was a Bart Allen
clone from the 30th century.
He was created as a weapon to be used in the
past against the flash family but also became
a velocity nine speedster.
So he was faster than Jay Garrick but not
as fast as Bart Allen who he was clone from.
So next on the list is obviously Bart Allen.
Then next on the list is's savitar just because
he had the ability to steal speed from other
people and then eventually was trapped in
the speed force, so this is where you start
to get some twists and turns with the way
people's powers work.
So your technically if to speedsters are running
against each other in one of them can steal
the speed of the other the slower speedster
would still be faster, just because he slowing
the other person down so because savitar had
the ability to manipulate the speed force
like that.
That's why he's higher than Bart Allen on
this list and this is comic book savitar,
so next up is Barry Allen in the comics Barry
Allen is the source of the speed force.
He did not exist before his accident when
he runs he generates speed force, so no Barry
Allen equals no speed force which explains
why eobard Thawne is not allowed to kill him
which is actually part of the plot of legends
of tomorrow the seasons all explained that
when I talk about the TV speedsters.
The next on the list is eobard Thawne just
a little bit faster than Barry Allen and he
also wields the negative speed force.
Meaning that he can also slow.
The other speedsters down which is why he's
a little bit higher than Barry Allen on the
list.
But then just a little bit faster than them
is the black flash which is basically like
the aspect of death for speedsters.
So the reason why put it on the list just
ahead of Barry Allen is because it was created
during the Wally West era and during that
time Wally was faster than Barry.
So if Wally was just barely able to out run
the black flash.
That means the black flash should be just
a little bit faster than Barry Allen and eobard
Thawne for that matter.
But then next on the list is the classic Ginger
Wally West from Mark Wade era.
He ultimately became the fastest version of
the flash but that was when Barry Allen was
still dead in the comics so had Barry been
around they might have been just a little
bit faster a part of it is really that they
just wanted to push the flash comics to new
territory they wanted to define the speed
force the speed force is a concept wasn't
created in the comics until the Wally West
era so that's why Wally became faster than
Barry, but really they're almost the exact
same speed which is Wally is like a little
bit faster.
Next up is God speed from the flash rebirth.
He was so fast he could be in two places at
once and was only defeated when kid flash
Wally West and Barry Allen siphoned off enough
of his speed to slow him down so next up getting
a little bit weird there are speedsters that
are faster than comic book Wally West but
gets a little funny.
So next on the list is Iris West Wally's daughter,
also named Iris West, I know people think
Iris West in the thing about Candice Patton
Wally West and Linda Park had a daughter in
the sun jive West and Iris West.
They discolor Iris West to in the comics so
she also got speed force powers in accident
but then became the living embodiment of the
speed force, so effectively for little while.
She had limitless speed force powers, but
next on the list is zoom who did not use the
speed force he actually just affected time
relative to himself so he could either slow
you down.
He could speed you up so he's the fastest,
but only because he's cheating technically.
You either call him the slowest because he
slows everyone down, so he moves really slow
but relative to him, everyone else moves much
much slower or you could call in the fastest.
So he's a bit of a wildcard pick, but the
very fastest number one on the list is the
God of death Barry Allen from Darkside war
where he becomes merged with the black racer
and gains the powers of a new God.
So he is the most powerful fastest version
of any flash ever.
But now moving onto the TV show.
So we've seen a lot of flash family get their
powers, as well as reverse flash family, like
the evil speedsters.
So the thing you have to remember in the thing
I try to account for is that this is relatively
early and say like Barry Allen's development.
So he's not as fast as he will eventually
become so this list is current as of right
now episode nine in season three of the flash
versus Jesse quick she got her powers last
year during the big particle accelerator accident
when they try to reboot Barry's powers as
well as Wally West, who is next on the list
got his powers recently because of the philosopher's
stone, but really what that was doing a lot
of people were confused about this flashpoint
Wally got his powers in an accident while
he was racing his car that was like the lightning
that struck Barry in season one of the flash
so the current version of Wally the got his
powers from the philosopher's stone that was
really just restoring the original version
of speedster Wally West.
So technically Wally's powers don't flow from
the philosopher's stone.
They still come from the speed force, and
I know they made a big deal about him being
faster than Barry, but that just at this point
in his development.
So next is the TV show version of the rival.
Edward Clariss little bit faster than Wally
West not quite as fast as a Barry Allen or
some of the other new speedsters like savitar,
so next on the list is Jay Garrick not quite
as fast to say Barry, but understands the
speed force and can use it better than Barry
can.
So that's why he's able to chase Barry through
wormholes yank him out of the time stream
when he's trying to reboot flashpoint again
that actually happen in episode two, where
he try to go back another time daycare just
going to them right out though Jay Garrick
is a much better fighter but his top speed
is still slower than Barry Allen's.
So next on the list.
Obviously Barry Allen who is suffering from
comic book Wally West mental block right now.
So even though Barry is faster than most of
the other flash family he'll get much faster
once he overcomes that mental block.
He'll have to in order to defeat's savitar
a lot of people were wondering about this
how fast will he get soaked think about how
fast savitar is right now he will be faster
than that but not until the very end of the
series it's all about progression he of all
is just a little bit more each new season
grant Gustin teased that we would see a new
suit soon.
He said that Barry is due for a new suit.
That's probably going to be of FlashForward
where we see the older version of Barry Allen
who will be much faster than current Barry
Allen.
So get hype about that but next on the list
is eobard Thawne TV show reverse flash is
a little bit faster than Barry and next on
the list.
We get to our velocity nine speedsters.
So we learned that velocity nine made trajectory
almost as fast as zoom but it was completely
unstable.
So her body just flew apart at the seams.
Same thing with zoom that was also faster
than Barry Allen because of velocity nine
in the fact that he was stealing speed from
Barry but was ultimately carried off by the
time wraiths, so number one fastest speedster
on the TV show right now is savitar because
he is stuck in the speed force, so instead
of running through three-dimensional space.
Like all the other speedsters he actually
jumps into the speed force.
This extra dimensional place runs through
that and then pops back out.
So effectively it enables him to be in almost
all places at once, because he's pure energy,
so until Barry also learns to do that he will
not be as fast as savitar, so that's what
to be one of the new tricks that he has to
learn by the end of the season so here's my
big question for you how fast you think that
Barry is going to get at the end of this season
and what do you think that his new suit is
going to look like and do you think it'll
be a Flash Forward situation or do you think
that they're going to bust out the flash ring
remember they tease that last season in season
two.
He had the flash ring and earth two Harrison
wells was like give it to me maybe I can figure
it out.
So they just put that on the shelf.
They haven't come back to it since that meaning
that I think that will see some flash ring
later this season, but just for the nitpicker's
out there for those you asking is Godspeed
or TV show savitar faster technically savitar
would be faster because God speed is all about
splitting himself into two and every time
he does that he splits his power in half so
each of the two would be slower savitar would
kill one of them and then he would automatically
be slower permanently but congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner Alex pursau
you win of flash ring just be sure to private
message me on the back and my channel so I
can get your contact details what can happen
next is I'm in a post of Star Wars episode
eight episode nine Obi-Wan Kenobi video Star
Wars has a plan for OBI Wan.
So I'm going to explain that and why you haven't
heard a whole lot about him recently while
you guys wait for that to post you can click
here for the trailer for the next episode
of the flash and you can click here to learn
all about the Batman verse Harley Quinn in
the Gotham city Sirens movie.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!